when they are up there with a UFC
microphone and you are getting into
territory of homophobia transphobia like
is there I don't give anybody a leash
well I'm saying you a leash here is UFC
president Dana White uh defending
Strickland's right to just say what he
thanks you obviously give a Long Leash
to your Fighters about you know what
they can say when they are up there with
a UFC microphone and you are getting
into territory of homophobia transphobia
like is there I don't give anybody a
leash well I'm saying you a leash I'm
like free
speech Just troll what people say going
to tell people what to believe going to
tell people I don't tell any other human
being what to say what to think and
there's no leashes aren't any of
them what is your
question I was asking that question I'll
move on though yeah probably a good idea
you that's ridiculous to say I give
somebody a leash free speech Brother
people can say whatever they want and
they can believe whatever they want all
right so that is the position of Dana
White who is the president of the UFC
it's not his job to police all of his
guys now interestingly I think you could
make a a slightly counterargument on
that in that these guys represent his
organization and he is allow you know if
they were up there saying we want to
murder all these people like obviously
he would have some issue with that but
the the overriding driving force of what
he's saying of course of course it's not
only completely right but it's it's what
we've always want wanted no it's not
what we've always wanted it's what it's
the way we always kind of did it before
this woke thing infected absolutely
everything what's really amazing about
this is that Strickland he's going after
budl budl is now one of the biggest
sponsors of UFC they gave Dana White a
ton of money and suddenly Dana White is
now promoting Bud Light again so no
nobody's perfect in any of all this but
I will certainly give Dana White credit
right there for being like Oh one of my
guys is going after my major sponsor and
I'm going to defend his right to do it
isn't isn't that seriously
something